a former Donald Trump campaign aide says
special counsel Rob Amala can take a
hike Sam noon bug has been subpoenaed by
mother's investigation but in a series
of wild interviews today he said he's
going to refuse to appear on MSNBC he
ridiculed the entire idea of the
investigation I'm not going to answer
questions in front of a grand jury if
they do not explain to me why I have to
go in there because the idea that once
again that Donald Trump colluded with
Russia is a joke
why do reported is too smart to collude
with Donald Trump Donald Trump could
keep his mouth shut if food colluded
with him yeah he's letting it all hang
out that was a clip from his CNN
interview the great Deroy Murdoch is
with us and nobody's heard of this mr.
noon bogeys basically a guy thing he's
about half the age of Donald Trump who
was who was briefly involved in the
campaign and has now had a subpoena and
has decided he's not going to play along
well it's it's just you know it's none
Bergesen Catholic no nut Oh Brooke like
High Noon oh sorry Devin noonas it's all
so confusing look he's a guy in town and
here in New York he's got a law degree
practices as an attorney happens to be a
friend of mine
oh we're not very close but he would
describe sam nunn burgers a friend of
mine no so you're next for the big stuff
yeah well I actually I thought about
calling today in the middle of all this
night literally seriously thought well
if I call him who knows about gets
sucked into this giant Bob Muller
whirlpool it just seems to get bigger
and bigger as it as it moves away and
further away from Russia well look he's
got a point here because for a start I
mean I mean I regard federal justice as
essentially a racket they convict 97% of
the people they dragged into court which
is a percentage that Saddam Husein and
Kim jong-un would envy so they're
basically saying to you roll over for us
are we going to destroy your life so
this guy will is either looking at 100
years in jail or he'll be sleeping in a
dumpster around the back of the freight
yards I mean there's something actually
admirable in telling Muller to go stuff
it isn't there
look there's I do believe if you're
subpoenaed you ought it really should
show up I mean that that's part of the
justice system but when you talk about a
97 percent conviction rate that's not a
nicely balanced scales of justice
they're about like so they're not one
problem another is that these folks who
get brought in for these discussions
brought up to the Capitol Hill for
hearings they bring lawyers in and it
costs a lot of money right and if Sam
done Berg has any sense he'll go down
there with an attorney and it's gonna
cost him a lot of money I've got a
friend of mine who literally said to tap
into his children's college fund in
order to pay the legal bills required
for him to go and intensively testify on
Capitol Hill on all of this and I we
talked on the phone and he's quite
distraught about the huge expense he's
faced doesn't testify not even indict or
anything but isn't that what's
outrageous about this because let's say
you have one lawyer or two lawyers or
five lawyers the federal government Bob
Muller has a hundred and five lawyers in
Goodwin you can't compete on that and if
they run out of money they can print
more money I don't know any law firm in
America that prints its own cash no
Department of Justice does know you're
talking about essentially infinite
resources exact now we've we've had just
heard today again in just in the last
couple of hours that mullahs now
suddenly investigating not just Trump's
collusion with Russia but apparently
with potentially with other countries
too he's apparently met with a guy from
Lebanon and a guy from the United Arab
Emirates he may be have been colluding
with Belgium all this time and just
using the collusion with Russia as a
front for his collusion with Belgium
well that's right and you I'm American
you're Canadian I believe so I guess
without saluting so maybe I'd leave the
studio now while we still can look this
isn't still not allowed to collude with
Canadian data that we can collude with
you that's not very fair is it look this
all this started off as investigation of
Russian kahlúa Trump and Russian
collusion they found no evidence of this
after 18 years and what amazes me is
that Muller is so busy trying to find
something he doesn't exist or at least
is not heretofore and yet you have
massive collusion on the part of the
Democrats and the Russians and he's not
interested looking that yeah you you put
it this way the Tokyo column you say his
mullah and the
fire department they've taken the axe
and they broken down the front door and
they're looking for a tipped-over candle
in the Trump house whereas right next
door the Democrat House is a flame with
Russia burning to the ground exactly and
just a couple of examples obviously are
the Russian reset that's a collusion is
sort Hillary Clinton of course had the
Iranian one deal which she basically
approved in exchange for that transfer
of 20% of the US uranium supply to the
Kremlin donation of one hundred forty
five million dollars to the Clinton
Foundation why does why don't any of
Hillary's aides have to turn over all
their emails or the way like this poor
number it strikes me as amazing that not
only is are there no indictments they're
not even monazite events the question
you have a Boeing deal where Hillary got
involved with basically brokering a deal
to get 57-37 sold at Kremlin to air
afloat all of a sudden Boeing gives nine
hundred thousand dollars to the Clinton
Foundation then there's something called
Co colva which is sort of like the
Silicon Valley of Moscow
she helped all these American companies
go over there take a look
those companies signed up they in turn
gave six at least six point five million
dollars to the Clinton Foundation and
later we find out from the Pentagon that
that whole thing was a scam designed to
engage in espionage and steal American
technology no questions no interviews no
discussion no nothing the woman should
be locked up and hopefully help the
Russians break into the Democratic
National or absolutely you know lock her
up is now as much as ever before okay
great lock her up says divider always
great to see you slags
thanks a lot